ist dass endlich der endgültige beweis
für außerirdisches leben ein us
forschungsteam behauptet im inneren
eines meteoriten ein protein molekül
gefunden zu haben dass es so nicht auf
der erde gibt was bedeutet dieser
sensationelle fund für die astrobiologie
sind wir sind die menschen aliens klicks
um science-fiction gibt's täglich
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen es ist eine der großen fragen
der wissenschaft wenn nicht die größte
woher kommt das leben und jetzt scheint
es eine neue antwort auf diese frage zu
geben an us forschungsteam hatte den
meteoriten aspern 086 der bereits vor 30
jahren auf der erde aufgeschlagen war
genauer ins visier genommen und bei
ihrer analyse haben die fachleute einen
wirklich überraschenden fund gemacht das
forschungsteam behauptet das erste
außerirdische protein überhaupt
aufgespürt zu haben proteine sind
riesige hoch komplexe organische
eiweißmoleküle und sie bestehen aus
aminosäuren die wiederum zu den
wichtigen bausteinen des lebens zählen
ist da also ein außerirdischer lebens
baustein auf der erde gelandet dass nun
möglicherweise außerirdische protein
nennen die forschenden hämmerli team
konkret soll es sich aus ketten der
aminosäure glycin und hydroxyl glycin
sowie eisen sauerstoff und lithium atome
zusammensetzen chemisch gesehen ist
dabei vor allem spannend dass sich das
hämolytisch signifikant ein dort terium
an reicher dabei handelt es sich um ein
schweres wasserstoff isotope dass neben
dem proton auch noch über ein neutron in
seinem atom kern verfügt ein
gewöhnliches wasserstoffatom hat dagegen
nur ein proton im kern aber kein neutrum
das us forschungsteam ist überzeugt
davon dass der meteorit keineswegs mit
irdischen materialien kontaminiert wurde
sondern es sich tatsächlich um zitat das
erste außerirdische protein im inneren
eines meteoriten handelt das wiederum
schließen sie aus seiner chemischen
zusammensetzung demnach spricht der hohe
gehalt an deuterium eindeutig gegen ein
irdisches vorkommen eine solche
deuterium anreicherung findet sich nach
der ansicht der fachleute vor allem in
intercell
moleküle wolken und protoplanetaren
scheiben um junge sterne herum
dazu heißt es in dem aufsatz dies ist
der erste bericht über ein protein aus
einer außerirdischen quelle laut der us
fachleute die mithilfe hochpräziser
massenspektrometrie auf dieses ergebnis
gekommen sein wollen wäre das eine
sensationelle premiere denn bisher
konnten zwar organische materialien
zucker und andere moleküle im meteoriten
aufgespürt werden proteine bislang aber
noch nie allenfalls konnten bislang
vereinzelt aminosäuren und ihre moleküle
im all entdeckt werden allerdings nie
als vollständiges protein was er auch
eigentlich total unwahrscheinlich ist
weil diese moleküle so hochkomplexe doch
dieses ergebnis muss man mit vorsicht
geniessen denn die studie hat das so
genannte peer review verfahren bislang
noch nicht durchlaufen also hierbei
werden ja die ergebnisse offiziell von
unabhängigen forschern dann bewertet und
begutachtet manche fachleute werden
diesen fund als beweis dafür dass die
bausteine des lebens im all entstanden
sind und dann über meteoriten und
asteroiden auf die junge erde gelangten
falls sich das ergebnis als korrekt
herausstellen zeigt es jedenfalls dass
solche chemischen grundlagen und
strukturen die für lebensnotwendig sind
selbst im weltraum außerhalb der erde
entstehen somit wäre die logische
schlussfolgerung das leben im gesamten
kosmos weit verbreitet sein könnte denn
fest steht proteine erfüllen enorm
wichtige funktionen für die zellen 100
prozentig beweis für außerirdisches
leben wäre der fund allerdings nicht
aber ein wink mit dem zaunpfahl das wäre
so als würde man ein gebiss finden und
dann darüber spekulieren ob es zu einem
lebewesen gehört oder eher geologischer
natur wäre allerdings häufen sich die
indizien fachleute weltweit finden immer
mehr beweise für sehr komplexe chemie
auch jenseits der erde
doch noch sind nicht alle forschenden
überzeugt dazu beispielsweise sehr schön
mit jeffrey bader zu space de ich bin
von diesen berichten nicht beeindruckt
das hauptproblem ist dass die aminosäure
hydroxyl glycin bislang noch niemals in
einem meteoriten gefunden wurde zudem
auch noch nie in einem protein ich finde
es deswegen sehr kurios dass diese
aminosäure in einem meteoriten enthalten
sein soll und deswegen bin ich den
ergebnissen gegenüber sehr misstrauisch
dass west forschungsteams
jetzt möchte sich dazu nicht äußern
bevor ihre studie nicht dass peer review
verfahren durchlaufen hat bis dahin
müssen wir uns also noch gedulden auch
wenn es sehr schwer fällt denn das
ergebnis würde ja auch bedeuten dass das
leben auf der erde aus dem weltraum
stammen könnte und wer hier auf der erde
der außerirdische wurzeln haben mit
allen konsequenzen
dunkle materie spektrum erklärt die
erfahrt ihr hier vom renommierten
wissenschaftsmagazin was es damit auf
sich hat also anklicken anschauen und
den neuen kanal spektrum video bei uns
im wissenschafts netzwerkes 1054
abonnieren bis dann bleibt dran